Most data needs a closer look and at least a few
fixes. For example, this is a picture of my house. Well,
actually it's not my house it's actually the house next door.
But in it's street map view, Google Maps believes this is
actually my house. Here's another quick example. So this is the
Wikipedia page for the Volkswagen Beetle. And probably the most common
name for the beatle is bug. And you can see here
that the nickname is bg. It's just a type but a
great example of the kinds of errors you can get anytime
humans are involved in producing data. Which is always. Let's take
a look at one more example before we move on. This
is some financial data that I worked with several years ago and
a couple of interesting things to note here. One is that
this line here is missing values for most of the fields, there
are lots of reasons why that might be the case, this
is the type of thing that we've got to look for anytime
we're dealing with data. Another example here Has to do
with what assumptions we might have about the dates. If you
look at these we might assume that this actually means
August 4th, 2008, certainly if you're an American, that's the type
of assumption that you'd make. But then we get to
dates like this and there's another example here, where it becomes
pretty clear that this is probably a date format In which
the day comes first. So we've got to be careful about
any assumptions we bring with us into a data
wrangling task. So let's go ahead and spell this
out. We need to asses our data in order
to test assumptions about the values that are there. The
data types for those values and the shape of
our data. We also need to identity errors or outliers
in our data. We're going to look at several ways
of testing our data to see whether there are errors
present or whether we have data that's really outside the range
of expected values. And finally, we need to access whether there are
any missing values within our data. In addition to all of
this, we also need to make sure that our data will support
the type of queries that we need to make. The idea
here is to eliminate surprises leading to bad analysis later. We'll go
into all of this in lesson three, but before can clean any
data, we need to make sure we know how to gather data.
And that's what we're going to be looking at in
the rest of this lesson, and the lesson that follows.